hey
looks like we are live
i'm just gonna take a step back because
when i can actually see you guys there's
so much bright light coming at me thank
you very much for showing up under these
circumstances i'm really happy to see uh
people here i was a bit afraid um
and
let me get something off my chest right
away i might have lured you here on the
false pretenses so who can claim best
practices in this world
i think maybe if you have a certain
fowler you can get away with that um
so
what i hopefully will give you here is
good ideas right
they're not going to be dogmatic i'm not
going to go and tell you this is what
you always must do this is good ideas
for inspiration i hope they're good
ideas
and
i hope you will enjoy them and
if you don't give me feedback right or
if you have some input i i want to learn
like everybody here right so
with expectations sufficiently lowered i
hope we can get going and maybe i can
get you from a red card over to a green
card by the end of this talk
so who am i uh well
my name is eagle and i'm from denmark i
live in iceland so
and now we're here in norway so we have
almost just missing sweden in there
somehow and then we have the whole
scandinavia almost
you can find me on twitter at
eaglehensen and if you uh
are watching this from the future or
just from your hotel room right now feel
free to tweet at me i love to answer
questions and help out so that's okay
i am a developer at this great company
uh delegate danish i.t consultancy we
specialize in in mice the microsoft
ecosystem so everything from low code
solutions all the way to you know big
custom solutions in asia and and you
know building on the newest news
latest.net tech
we have a bunch of these diggers on our
website i'm not sure what they exactly
mean but if some of this sounds
interesting to you we always looking
like everybody else i guess uh for for a
new talent for great talent uh so if if
any of this sounded something
interesting to you feel free to reach
out to me and and and let's talk right
anyway
i'm also microsoft mvp but more
importantly for this talk i am the
creator of b units the testing library
we will cover here
if you um for some reason or another
would like to see more of me you can do
so uh i try to be very very regular live
streaming on twitch just coding on b
unit or other open source things and
feel free to come and hang out and
ask your questions or just you know make
fun of me everything is valid there
quick disclaimer i don't know how many
of you attended chris sainz's workshop
earlier this week or
just have a general knowledge of blazer
and testing in general but i won't cover
those concepts here so it's not a
beginner
talk of
covering blazer or just testing so if
you're completely new to that that's
going to be some words today that you
might not understand that's okay you can
ask afterwards if you like
okay so let's start with the first
question what is b unit and why do i
need it
and
well the first question would be what is
b unit so
b unit is a
is a library a library obviously for
testing basic components but
the reason why i sort of underline
library is because it's not a testing
framework like you would normally use
for writing your test like you would use
x unit or n unit or ms test those are
test frameworks be units library that
you add on top of that similarly to
what you do when you add something like
a fluent assertions library or
or a mocking library so beyond something
that we add on top of our testing
frameworks in a similar way it's a
library that enables us to test laser
components obviously
that also means that b units
will well b unit tests will sort of look
and behave exactly the same as your
regular unit test right so because it's
just something we add on top of our
existing testing library that also means
that we can reuse all the goods patterns
and practices we have around structuring
our tests you can write you can
basically continue writing your tests
like you would normally in in b unit
one thing i do want to highlight that
might surprise people that have maybe
done some selenium testing or similar
front-end testing previously in the net
ecosystem
where you have a browser involved where
maybe selenium is sort of it will spin
up a browser in the background and it
will hook into that and instrument that
and
look at what the markup is being
generated and you can sort of
interact with your application on the
test through selenium but b unit doesn't
do any of that and that also means
it doesn't run any of your javascript so
it runs entirely under the for example x
unit runner and everything in there will
there's no javascript engine in that so
if you have a component or an
application blaze application that uses
some javascript well your javascript
won't be tested with b unit while you
are testing your components
what we do have in b unit is a way for
you to set up those expectations
very much like a mocking library where
you can say well i expect my component
to make this call to javascript to the
ijs runtime and that way you can sort of
test the expected interaction
and
i think most place applications actually
don't have too complex javascript most
of the javascript we will have in our
applications it's not application logic
it's more like enabling us to call maybe
some browser apis
so
for the most part that's not going to be
a problem uh but if you have complexion
text maybe you're building a complex uh
component library where you do have a
need to sort of do that in trend testing
maybe look at at uh
what it's not storytelling but the the
new thing that microsoft is also coming
out with for instance website testing
that's going to be the option you want
to go with
and um
but
the advantage of bu not running any
browser under the hood and not doing any
of the usual end-to-end browser
front-end testing is that the test runs
just like regular unit tests they run
fast like we're talking milliseconds
here on a regular pc so you get the
speed and benefit and you also get we
also have fairly deep hooks into the
blazer render which means that we can
make the tests quite a bit more stable
and predictable
so
but let's get
let's see just what i mean by that so
here we have a
regular x unit cs project file from
the.net 6 error and we need to make a
few modifications so that to enable b
unit so the first thing we want to do is
we want to
add the change the sdk to to be the
microsoft.net sdk razer type because
we need to write razor files in our test
library so that's all we need to do and
although obviously we need to add b unit
as well as a packet reference and that's
all you need to do
the next question we might quickly want
to cover is why do we actually need b
units so
a blazer component itself is just when
you look at the generated markup from a
blazer component or just create one
manually just to see in the sharp class
it's actually just a c-sharp class right
so when i before i built b unit i wanted
to test my blazer components and i was
like let me just new that thing up and
try to test it from just the next unit
chest phone but
you quite quickly realize when you
attempt that that well you need a few
things
so
components have life cycle methods and
sort of to to be truthful to the
environment that a component would be
used in in production you have to
emulate that life cycle and and call
them methods at the right time under the
right circumstances right
so we have to do that that's something
beard will help you with another thing
but helps you help you with is passing
parameters and injecting services into
your components at the right time in the
right way that the laser runtime does it
as well another thing the unit does is
allow you to call event handlers so
event handlers can sometimes just be
public methods on your components
sometimes they are actually just inline
lambdas on the markup itself that's
going to make them a bit harder to call
most of the time i would assume they're
going to be private methods that you
have in your components so again it's
kind of hard to call them in a test
spirit will help you with that as well
and
when you think about it
the architecture of blazer works such
that a laser component doesn't actually
know how to render markup output it
sort of contains this description of
what we want to produce through the
razer language which is a template
language and then we need something else
to turn that template into markup that
we can show on screen to the users and
that is also something that that is also
why we need actually a real blazer
runtime underneath the hood to do that
for us and luckily that is basically
what being you know this being it builds
on the existing laser run time and the
blazer renderer but just instead of
sending that output to a browser well we
capture that so that you can inspect and
work with that output from the component
we capture the instance of the component
so you can inspect that as well if you
need to so that is why being used is
necessary
so what does the hello world of the unit
look like so we've all seen this
component i i is there any blazer
developers in here that haven't seen
this component before this is the
counter component and in case you've
forgotten what it looks like you have
that button and you click it on the
counter increment so what is the test
for this how does this test look
well
to begin with uh obviously we are going
to go into eraser file so this is a
counter test.razer file and
and uh
the first thing we need to do is
obviously have a x unit i'm using x unit
in this case so we have an actual test
here and the first thing we need to do
in that test is to new up a test context
so the test context you're going to see
that all through this talk it's a b unit
thing that's the thing that allows you
to do things with a razor component so
when we have one of those
well we can call its render method and
we pass in the counter component tell it
to render the counter component the
result of that is an eye rendered
fragment
and it's abbreviated the variable is re
abbreviated cut for component under test
so if you know
uh regular testing nomenclature that
would be system under test normally but
i sort of changed that to big components
that makes sense to me so now we have
the component now we need to click that
button and how do we do that well we can
go ahead and actually use a css selector
through the find method to go and walk
into the document object model so we
actually have a full document object
model through the angle sharp library
that we're using under the hood to go in
and and find
elements document objects
in the dom tree that was produced by the
counter component and we're going to
look for the button component and then
we will call the click method click
method is a
event trigger method that will go ahead
and trigger that unclick event
handler method that was on the button
component
in in the class in the components and
once we've done that well now we go
ahead and find the paragraph component
the p tag in our component and then we
use this method here called markup
matches it's a custom assertion method
in p unit that will allow us to pass in
some magnum that we now expect the
paragraph component to contain in this
case we want the
we want the
the one uh to be incremented from zero
to one so now we should set current
count as one and and so if you haven't
seen a b unit test before you might sort
of
wonder what are these things i've
highlighted in red here uh and it's
inline render
and it's a weird it's a mouthful
ringline render fragment i think it's
actually have a more official name but i
call it inline render fragments so this
is sort of amazing that you can in
in blazer you can actually have a razer
file where you start out with an eraser
context then you add the code block and
then you go into c-sharp context but
then from the code block in physicians
from c-sharp content you can actually
get in the back into razer context and
write markup just like you would with
code and you have syntax highlighting
you have intellisense on the html so
that makes it
much easier to to to sort of describe
the component you want to test pass
parameters to it and also provide markup
that you want to verify against and you
can obviously run and write your test in
c sharp then you don't get access to
this notation then you have to use sort
of a builder pattern i have around that
for example to pass parameters and you
have to use strings when you want to
verify markup like this and that can be
a little tedious if you want to escape
so attributes for example that that's
things like you you have to escape in
that case
so
now that we have a test how do you run
it so running a b unit test is just like
running any other dot net test basically
if you can run from the test you can run
b unit test i've added a extra argument
here to get us a better a little bit of
better logging output so when we run the
test we get that one and then you can
see the test run and everything is happy
and everything is green that's good so
now that you know
how to do build b unit tests the next
question you might want to answer or ask
is what do i actually verify do i look
at the markup
or do i
test a component functionality or
something completely different
so let's cover that
so let's start by
what i would call functionality testing
or component logic testing
i don't know how many of you have seen
the
blazing pizza workshop before a few of
you okay if you haven't
uh there are some urls at the bottom of
the slide here you can you can go and
check that out it's uh it's if if you
fell in youtube blazer it's a great
workshop to work through you would see
those two urls up there one of them is
uh to a
not a new version of the workshop but
it's sort of it has a version of the
workshop where i've added tests for for
all the components and there's also a
whole video series and did online on
twitch where i go through the full
workshop it's like a 12 uh like 24 hours
something total so you might want to
fast forward through some of the bits
but
anyway in this case we just have a
dialogue box so my user has selected a
pizza they want to buy the buffalo
chicken and now they have the option of
adding extra toppings so that is sort of
the component on the test we want to
test so how would we test the
functionality of that component
so first obviously we need our tests so
selecting toppings from drop down adds
it to pizza so what do we want to add
here well first we need a test context
and then we add a p then we need a new
pizza
and now we can go ahead and render our
component and then configure the
configure pizza dialog and we pass in
the pizza
so
it might look like i'm actually passing
in the string pizza here but it actually
works just like it works in real race or
markup it's actually that pizza variable
there is pointing all the way up to the
pizza we have instantiated just on the
line above
so the next thing we need to do is we
need to go into again using the find
method and passing in the css selector
that will allow us to find the select
drop-down list and then we just call the
change method on that that is a callback
that will trigger the unchanged event
handler that is bound to the list
drop-down or sorry of the drop-down list
and that will change it to a topping
value and now our assertion would be
well now we assure that the pizza
toppings list is no longer empty so the
key thing here about the functionality
testing is that we have very little tie
into the marker that is actually
rendered by the component the only thing
we really focus on is the
we have a bit we're a little bit tired
to to the markup in a way that we have a
selecting so a select there uh where we
go and pick out something from the dom
but all the other markup that's been
generated all the drop down and
everything inside of that we don't
really care about that so that means
that our component sorry this test for
the component is likely going to keep
working and keep
being green even if we go and change
around a few things in the markup add
another attribute or something to the
drop down list or change the styling for
example so this is sort of what you get
with functionality testing you poke at
the thing and you watch it react to what
you do
another thing we can do this week if
it's important you can go and verify
markup and and
you might want to do that
if you for example have a designer or
you are the designer of the company that
told you that this css and this markup
goes together and if they know if the
markup isn't exactly like this well then
we have a problem because when things
don't work as expected out in the
browser so sometimes it actually makes
sense to go ahead and
verify markup that is produced
and historically that has been a bit
hard
and because if you take a string of html
and compared to another string of html
you can do a lot of things to that
original string of html
that will still make it semantically the
same
but
will not really actually be
if the string equals won't work it will
like break the test even though the
markup is actually still fine so
the point here i want to make is if you
want to verify markup do it semantically
and b unit has a semantic compare that
we can help that can help us do that so
semantic comparison means that two html
bits are the same
if they actually look the same to the
user on the browser the opposite is
obviously what i told you before is that
well if you use string comparison well
then you're going to have a harder time
making that test stay green every time
you do a little bit of refactoring move
around white space let's look at an
example so sort of to get the point
across
so
suppose we have this button style
dialogues buttons uh razor component
with this simple markup in it and we
have this test that ver that verifies
that the markup is correct and the the
three the key here is is the markup
matches method that's built into b unit
that is the semantic comparator that is
built into the unit so
if i go ahead and change my dialogue
button just do a control kd maybe in
visual studio and reformat it well this
test will still pass because these
things these two
this markup we had before in the
dialogue button and then one we have now
they will look the same to the user in
the
on on screen
we can also go ahead and change the all
of attributes in that component and the
test will still pass because they work
the same for the use on the browser
we can even go ahead and change the
order of the classes in the class
attribute and the test will still pass
it won't care
another thing we could do is well
maybe we have an id attribute in this
case where some of it is generated or
it's and it's good or something well
that's going to be quite hard to test
because it would change every time you
render the component right it's sort of
like a you want a unique ud id for
example well we have
in in b units cement and compare we have
what i call comparison modifiers in this
case we have the the i we have the regex
modifier that's highlighted on screen
now where you can pass in the red red x
regex and instead of using just straight
up comparison it will use a regex
comparison so that allows you to sort of
again handle that scenario where you
don't want the chest to break
there's many more another one that is
quite common to use is this more general
div ignore modifier that basically says
i know that's supposed to be an element
here but just ignore it we don't care
about that
so
now we know sort of different different
approaches to what we can test and and
and how to do that but let's talk a bit
let's change gears a bit and talk about
what is a testable component and how do
we write maintainable chests
and um i don't know how many of you in
here like chester and development i'm
personally
that's sort of something that suits the
way i work and it makes me feel
comfortable that makes me feel like i
can you know
better get to a state where things are
done but
that's not really the point of this so
you can do test first the test after
either way but
um
the point of us writing tests in the
first place is to
be able to maintain our code
in the future obviously also to verify
that the thing we are building right now
is working as intended and so if writing
tests doesn't make necessarily make
sense if you're just doing a quick
prototype of something uh unless of
course you're prototyping with b unit
and trying things out with b and so
but
i want to talk a bit about what it means
for me to create testable maintainable
components because that's sort of where
we start and
again i want to what i iterate this is
just
my approach and it's definitely not
necessarily the right approach for
everybody and for every fall scenario so
take this as good ideas i'm not um dark
matter right so
i think a component should do one thing
well and what does one thing mean well
it's sort of perhaps hard to define but
that could be a few code smells or
component smells i guess that we could
look for to sort of identify when a
component doesn't do that one thing so
one
one thing i would like to like to
look for in my components is if there's
a mix of abstraction levels
and even the term itself abstraction
levels is abstract so i'll show an
example in a little bit so we can sort
of see what i mean by that another thing
would be
uh the level of cohesion and generally
if the component has low cohesion again
an abstract term will i'll show you an
example then that might be an indication
that the component is more complex than
it needs to be
and one thing i see and i even see that
and i see that a lot of demos maybe i
can't even remember if they still do
that in the hello world when you sort of
find a new project blazer
they inject http client directly in a
component that's not super ideal
especially for testing but it also sort
of limits you that you basically have
your http code directly in your
component you might want to move that
into a service so in general don't have
infrastructure in your components put
that outside similar to what we do when
we're building business logic this is
component logic keep service keep
infrastructure keep databases and http
clients and what have you out of your
components and work with transactions
instead
so
to sort of have something to look at
let's let's create a dynamic data table
component so this is the like the the
the grid test uh that we've all seen a
few times so our dynamic data table
component will work like this here at
the bottom of the screen we have a
dataset component we pass in some movies
to it
and uh the movies are defined above
right now but that could come from
anywhere and when the data table
component renders it figures out based
on the based on the movie type what
headers to add and it also figures out
you know how to render each of the reach
each of the columns each of the rows in
the table uh based on the data we passed
into it so this is sort of a very
dynamic very i'll figure it out for you
kind of a component
so how do we build something like this
well
the first thing we need we need some
system dot reflection because this is
clearly gonna use reflection to figure
all that stuff out
we also need it to be a generic
component so that's why we have the type
program on top and then we need a
parameter where we can pass our items
into then we need some reflection magic
this is going to go and find the
items property info
and it will only find the ones the
problem the public properties of our
item that is public and that is instance
and that we can actually read
and then we need a helper method to be
able to get the names of the columns so
that is this method here it will go and
get the names of each of the properties
that we can read and we can that our
instance are part of the item finally we
need a little bit helpful method that
can go ahead and fetch out the data for
each row it looks like this
and
if we scroll down a little bit we will
see that obviously we need a table and
we need the table head it looks like
this we have a for each over the column
name and we print out
in a table row we print out the table
header cells and with the name of that
and finally in our tea body we have a
for each again over the items and then
in a table row we for each over each of
the cells in in that table row and print
that out so this is the total of that
component that would do that thing so
quite simple
but still
this is the things that we can do to
make this more testable maintainable in
the future is there any code spells that
you
are thinking that even this simple
component i think maybe it's 30 lines is
there something that actually
could make this more easy to work with
in the future well
if we go back
to the examiners we had before
sort of my recommendations the first
thing i've sort of skipped away a few
things here but the first thing is the
mix of abstraction levels so what does i
what do i actually mean by abstraction
levels so an abstraction level is
like in this case we have
a component that works uh this part of
the component sort of deals with the
items with plural
that sort of a higher level abstraction
we're working with multiple items
whereas
this bit of the code works on the
individual item and that is sort of a
mix of abstraction level that's two
things that that you might sort of
indicate that maybe there's something
here i can pull into sub components
and
another thing we talked about was the
cohesion so
we want to eliminate low cohesion so low
cohesion what does that mean well
let me illustrate that by saying well
these two bits here that are red now
they clearly are dependent on each other
there's a there's a coupling between
them because the the margaret is using
the method up there
but the blue bits here
they don't have any relation
to the red bits they could exist
somewhere else and the red bits wouldn't
care
so that is sort of an example of low
cohesion and the concept low cohesion is
something that also applies to classes
and
and just regular plain old c sharp
objects in that you can have an object
that grows too large and one of the
indicators of that is that it have parts
of the parts of the class
that deals with things that only they
don't use a subset of the fields for
example only use this option of the
properties there so the same thing here
that also is an indicator that we have
things that don't necessarily need to be
in the same component and we can
simplify things so
let's do some refactoring
the first thing we would like to do is
probably to take that thing that they
have in common that item property info
property i realize that name is going to
be a mouthful and just refactor that
into um
into a helper class so we have a data
helper uh type now that has that
functionality in it so that we can reuse
that across components and let me just
show you that what looks what that looks
like so you can see we just moved that
property into a class and now it's a
method and we can call it and we get
that information out
so
the next thing we would always want to
do is get rid of that header stuff so
let's pull that out and add in instead a
data table header component and the only
thing that data table header component
needs is actually the type the t item
type because that's all it needs to
actually render out the
the header columns
so and here we have a data table header
component and you can see this is a nice
concise component that's easy to
understand what it does
and
you know let's jump let's go uh go
forward with the next thing so the next
thing and i'm probably you guessed that
by now is that we have the row
bits we move out and
we end up with a data table row where we
for each of the data double rows we pass
in an item so this data table row
component is now responsible for
rendering a single row out
and
as you can see it's also
very simple
and now this is the final refactor data
table component again focus simple that
is sort of one abstraction level here
we're only working on items the items
pro level and and we sort of delegate
the responsibility of the individual
item of the header down to child
components of the datatype component
and i guess one
argument you would say well this was so
simple why do you need to take that step
well
this is also very rudimentary it's not
going to go not going to take
many many many weeks before your manager
comes and says can we get some sorting
in here can we and we then you start
adding logic where you can click on the
header for example that should do
something and then it should start
sorting somewhere else and maybe you
want some editing in the cells and all
of a sudden you have a component that
went from a nice 30 lines to
very big instead now you can move that
logic out into the different child
components and still have fairly clean
cohesive code so
it might seem overkill but i actually
think there are some some
meaning to the madness in this case
so
now that we have something we can we
want to test so how do we create
maintainable tests
it turns out when i was
doing this sort of for building the
slides of this talk many of many of the
recommendations i'm going to give here
now in terms of building maintainable
tests are actually going to be
generalized to unit testing in general
and not be specific to to blazer
components that's going to be some
obviously but
in general i like even in my just
regular test to avoid duplicated code
within tests so i don't mind duplication
across tests necessarily test classes
sorry test classes but i i would like to
avoid duplicated code within a test
class so all tests in a test class
should sort of be very
they should have the same
uh the same sort of uh tight target they
should have the same system on a test or
same component on the test in this case
and and and but but you might have
components that exist or other tests
that might have some similar setup logic
for example but
they then you might end up with if you
have too much yet code between test
classes then you might be in a situation
where you can't change the test logging
in one class without actually breaking
another assist so i i i don't follow
that no duplicated code religiously but
at least within a test class it's very
always a good idea i think
so how can you get around that well use
sort of move common
arrange code
or setup code into the constructor of
its x unit or into the appropriate setup
methods in your testing library so you
sort of have that duplicated code moved
somewhere else
i also like to use creational patterns
to create
input for tests and i've also uh i also
enjoy using tools like auto fixed or
bogus to generate test data that is not
really specific to the test but just
data that needs to be there
and
and if you are if i'm building um using
creators creational patterns to create
test data that is actually test specific
i like to try to use the business
domains in wording because that's again
going to make my test easier to read and
understand if i have sort of high level
language that explains
with this input something is going to
happen
this is a obviously a specific point but
only verify markup that belongs to the
component on the test
so
if you have a component that has
multiple child components
use for example the the difficult to
ignore subparts of the markup that you
are from the component on the test that
belongs to the child components because
you don't want
your component on assist to break just
because a child component changes the
way it renders output you don't want
that you don't want one test breaking
when there's no reason to
and finally
i've heard people talk about this before
but i like to say stick to one logical
assertion per test you can have multiple
assertion statements in your test but a
test should primarily have one logical
assertion so that means one sort of
business business rule and
one thing i like to do and i'm a big fan
of fluent assertions is to actually
create custom assertion methods if i
have multiple assertion statements so
that i'm getting down to one assertion
line again just to make my test readable
more maintainable more easy to
understand when i look at my code again
in half a year or god forbid somebody
else does
so let's do some testing let's look at
uh testing the data table component
and
the first refactoring we can do from the
first examples is to well let's have our
test class our test component in this
case inherit from date from b units test
context then we don't have to move that
up in every single test so that's a
little bit of
niceness there that allows us to just
call the test context methods directly
so now we can go ahead and write the
first test and the test is going to be
the most simple thing we can come up
with data table renders basic table of
head and body so this is our
verification of the marker produced by
the data table that it owns and the only
thing we do is we call the render method
we pass in the data table and we don't
pass any items because that would be a
more complex scenario we just pass in an
object as the generic type so that we
get the most basic test we can do
and now we just use the markup matches
to verify
that the markup is indeed right and here
we're using the div ignore children
because we know there should be a t hat
there but we don't care about what the
data table header component the child
component is generating so we are just
telling it to ignore the child content
of the table head
the next test we might want to write
would be to sort of test that
composition that interaction between the
data table and the data table header
component so
even though we're not going to test the
markup output from the data sample
component in a data table
testing class we might we want to test
that we are passing the right stuff down
to the data table header component so
it's like
what you do with testing that's that
sort of interaction testing between them
so how does that look well now that
we've rendered the datasheet component
what we can do also with bu is we can go
and inspect the not the dom tree then
produce marker but we can go in and
split the component tree and we do that
with the find component method and we
tell it to go ahead and find the child
component of type data table header uh
with a generic type of object and if it
doesn't return anything it will for an
exception so at this point we could
actually stop and say well as we
certainly did add the right child
component into the into the component
tree um but if we want to go one step
deeper we can go and say well let me
find the t hat
in our component on the test the data
table find the child nodes and say those
child nodes should match whatever the
data table header component produced
and this might it's
i'm sort of have this an example i
probably wouldn't do this in in in
practice but what we are actually doing
here is even though the data table
header component changes its output this
test would still pass because we're
basically just saying whatever you have
it should be in that t-head
and that's it
okay so
i'm going to skip showing you a test of
data table beta because it's not going
to be very interesting let's jump
a little bit further down and do a test
of
the data how the data table uses the
data table row so again an interaction
test a composition test so first we need
a couple of views to pass into our data
table to have something otherwise we
won't get anything rendered out
by the data table header we won't get
any iterating over and adding data
tables to a component so we render our
data table component again
and here
now we can use again we can use the find
components and that's you can might see
that there's this is there so it's a
plural thing and we find all the data
table row components that was added to
the
component tree
and now
well there's a little bit of magic we
can do so uh the result we get out of
that that contains an instance that
references the actual data table row
component and then we can go to the item
of that data table row and we can see
this is the item that was passed in so
now i have an innumerable of movies and
those are the moves that were added to
the rows in our data table and here i'm
using fluent assertion it has a fairly
magical and fantastic method called b
equivalent too so now i can say all the
movies in my rows
they should be equivalent to the
original movies and this will verify
that the thing that the individual
movies are if that's the same amount and
they're in the same order so this is
sort of a test way to test an
integration of between the data table
and digital component so let's look at a
test of a data table component
the first
test is just the empty test again
to to make sure that it works in the
basic test this is not very interesting
but you might want to have those like
the start when you do test and
development just kind of start with the
most basic test and then you're writing
something like this the next test is a
bit more interesting
here we pass in because the data probe
is only responsible for one movie here
we pass in a single movie and now we can
do a markup matches again and verify
that it does the right thing with that
movie we don't have really we don't have
any functionality at this point in our
data table row we just rent out output
but as you can see here this is actually
kind of great feature you have you can
even use that uh so as you can see we're
building our radar render fragment that
we passed to markup matches and that
actually uh points back to the movie we
originally uh movie variable a few lines
above so
this again will verify that
data table row if passed a movie or past
any object will do the right thing or at
least with a movie i guess
so
to summarize what have we done with this
testing well we have verified the
component markup and isolation of the
different components well we skipped the
data table header but you i think you
get the point
and and that allows us to evolve the
data table row and the data table header
and the data table component
individually without having their their
own tests breaking um and that's
important you don't want test breaking
in general in your unit testing
because something else changed right
another
thing we also did was we verified the i
call it component composition might be a
fancy word the way the components work
together and that is something that we
do want to verify uh especially from a
data table to the to the child foot to
his child components because that's part
of the contract they have like a public
contract and we want to make sure that
we're passing in the right things and
maybe getting the right callbacks
so
let's look at another approach
to sort of work around the issue
of
the dependencies that are between
components
so isolating the component under test so
in this very basic example i have a foo
component that's my component on a chest
and it has a char component
well
you can ask the question should changing
bar break through's test sometimes maybe
it's going to be a
it depends kind of an answer but if we
answer no to that question then we might
want to not have barb be part of our
chest but how can we do that well let's
get back to that another question we
might might ask is is bar a third party
component
maybe and i know it's quite common that
we will take a third-party component
with some great components in there and
use them in our blaze application
because that makes us go faster and we
don't have to do all that hard logic
perhaps but we don't want to test the
third-party components in our test right
because that's not our code it's not our
responsibility and that will also
help bind a
lock our tightly coupled our tests to
third-party components
in a way we probably don't want to so
not only when we upgrade to the latest
version of that third party component we
have test breaking but we might also
have other different issues there so
so sometimes you want to actually pull
away
the thing we don't unfortunately we
can't just remove things from the
component sweep because that's sort of
something you steadily code it into your
razor files but we can substitute
components and that's sort of down to
how blazer works so what do i mean by
substitution so let's look at an example
so
if fu doesn't have a bar that's our test
and we render foo
we want to have an assertion that looks
a bit like this we can use the health
component that's a b method where we can
ask do you have do the component test
have this child component and the answer
to do you have a bar component that
should be false but do you have a bar
substitute well that should be true and
how do we get around that so
that's uh it's sort of it's been around
since 1.2 of b unit a concept of
component factories a component factory
is the way that b unit allows us to
control
uh what
instance of a component actually is
so
blazer will ask bns component factories
can you create the please create me this
instance and then b and it will ask all
the component factories can you create
this and the first component factor even
says yes gets the chance to return an
instance of what was asked for but
blazer actually for the most part
doesn't care that the instance is the
right type so that is where the
component factors type come in so
let me just show you what this
particular bar substitute component
factor look like so it's just a thing
that implements i component factory it
has the two methods it tells can you
create this type and in this case we say
yes if the type is a type of bar and
then the great method gets called and we
just return a bar substitute because
that's how we roll
and the bar substitute is just a very
boring laser component that's the only
right thing it is
so how can we use this well
this is the test we had before where we
had to use that difficult children um
diff modifier well what if we can do
this instead
so
to save you from writing a whole bunch
of
i component factories there are
obviously some some of them built into b
units to make it a bit easier to work
with this is sort of the very basic one
that is available through this ad method
that has two generic parameters the
first generic parameter is the
type of the component you want to remove
from the dom tree or substitute out and
the second generic parameter is the
parameter
of it is the type of the component you
want to substitute with so and again the
the header substitute just looks like
this and now we have a more clean markup
matches call where we just specify the
marker that is relevant for the
component on the test
so there are a few rules for creating
substitute components and the first rule
is that well it has to be a component
maybe not surprising but all laser
components
have to inherit from i component that
happens by default if you inherit if you
if you build on uh component base
but
at the very minimum a component has to
inherit from i component
they also have to a substitute also
helps to implement or have the same
parameters as the component is
substituting
all and this is a super neat trick that
was just perfect for this use case
it can also have just the capture
unmatched values type of parameter so
imagine we have a component with a bunch
of parameters and if we return a
different component to blazer blazer
we'll then at that point try to uh bind
all the parameters to the properties it
is it is expecting to find there but if
they aren't known it will use look for
the captured unmatched values and we
find one of those it'll just drop all
the parameters into that so that means
we can make valid generic substitute
components better reusable
there is one thing that can make things
a bit more complex if you have code like
this where you have a child component
that you have and
use the adrev keyword with where you re
reference the the component well in that
case your substitute must actually
inherit from the thing it's substituting
otherwise blazer will not able to assign
that substitute component to the
variable we have in this case here the
private bar variable
but
it would kind of suck if you had to
create substitute components for all the
components you want to replace in your
blazer test so
part of the preview package that is out
right now for for for being it uh we do
have uh stop so anybody familiar with
testing nomenclature might know that we
have you have a we have box but stops is
sort of a more lightweight market
doesn't you can't really set up
expectations but it's just something
where you can say go and behave sort of
like this
so we have built-in stops uh component
and the stop component is a stop of the
type of component you're you're
substituting and it sort of it is a
blazer component obviously so so so we
get a thumbs up for the rule number one
that it should be a blazing component
it's also have that captures all
parameters features with a little extra
sprinkle on top so it makes it easier
for you to get at those parameters you
captured so you can insert against those
so rule number two also checks out rule
number three however we can't really do
that because stop of t
isn't
t so
we don't get to use ad ref uh when uh on
on the tar components
if and stop them out with this this
approach here but it makes things a
whole lot easier in many cases so again
if you look at the bar
and and food test well now we can just
do component factories that add stop off
bar and then it will stop out bar and
this is our test and it looks almost the
same as before now we just find a stuff
of bar in our component tree when we go
and search
you can also do this sometimes maybe you
want to have a stop that actually
produces some output some markup in the
dom tree
and
the approach to doing this is basically
to pass in
in a in a render template like we see
here and and give it some markup and
then you will find that markup in the
render tree you can see the markup
matches here it's probably not the best
example i could have come up with
because this sort of assumes that food
doesn't render any markup but
if you bear with me you can sort of see
what's going on here
another thing we can do is well maybe i
want to stop out everything from a
namespace or
if i have that third party component and
what you can simply do is you can pass
in that
you can pass in a type predicate a a
a
i guess it's a predicate that takes a
typos input and returns a boolean right
so if whenever you return true from from
this predicate the the component type is
going to be stopped out so this could be
something like this where anything that
is that this is an installation starts
with third party component is going to
be replaced and just moved out of the
way
and
you can even take it one step further i
don't know how many of you have heard of
shadow render before shadow renders sort
of a concept that exists in in other
front end frameworks like like react and
similar where it basically says share a
render of this component and that will
basically effectively only render the
component and ignore all the child
components
but we can emulate that quite easily we
can just say add stop and stop out
everything that isn't the type i'm
rendering that my component on interest
in this case foo and then you only get
to render foo no matter how many child
components you have now or in the future
so it's sort of a lightweight
way of doing shadow rendering
another thing
that we might want to do to sort of get
that third rule
uh is to do mocking and it turns out
that you can actually mock a component
using your most likely using your
favorite mocking library so if you're
using i've tested with moq and in
substitute i'm quite sure that terarex
just mark will work quite well with this
as well it might actually even work
better than the two because it also has
at least on the paid version ability to
do things with field types and with
non-virtual things
but you can actually just mock a
concrete type in using embarking tools
so you can say mock off foo or walk off
bar
and that will mock the component and why
does that work well
mox
inherits from the thing they mock
so that is the first thumb up we have
for rule number three
uh lifecycle methods on a standard
blazer component a component that
inherits from
the component base type which is the
default you get in blazer well all of
those are virtual
and virtual methods when mocked
they just get you know they just do
nothing unless you go and configure them
through the usual mocking setup logic
so basically
the component gets neutered it doesn't
do anything now because all the all the
lifecycle methods uh basically don't do
anything so it's so it's like having a
an empty component that only inherits
from component base the only exception
is that if the component you are marking
has a constructor that isn't virtual it
isn't soft it can't be sort of neutered
so the constructor will still run that
also means if you have any field
initializers or if you have any property
initializers those will also run unless
the properties are virtual
um and if you have any disposal dispose
async they will also run again unless
they are virtual so that's something to
be aware of so this is sort of a
this might not work in all cases but it
will definitely work in most cases i
think
and there's one little trick we have to
remember
and that is that mocking
uh sometimes you can't use the same mock
instance for muslims so if you have
multiple bars in the same foo you have
to actually pass in two different mocks
mock instances you can't reuse blazer
doesn't allow us to have two instances
of the same component different places
in the in in the component tree so
that's basically what that rule is
so let's look at an example
so marking a single component instance
how does that look so again we have the
foo and the bar example
and now i'm here i hear i'm using mock
but you know like i said most mocking
frameworks will probably work quite well
with this so we're just creating a mark
of bar
and we're using the add method uh to
pass in the mock object and say whenever
you see when you see one bar in the
component tree use this mark object
instead
and then again we render our component
and now we can actually go and
find bar in our component tree and why
can we do that because we because the
mark is actually a bar
so and that's actually what we want
because if we have that reference we
want a proper bar in our component tree
so that's also why we can go ahead and
find that component and the component
tree of type bar and now we can actually
go and look at the bar the in real
instance of the bark render component
and we can actually verify that it is
indeed the same instance as our unbox
component so this just shows that it
actually does the right thing it
actually replaces the insta the the
original bar with the with the mach bar
so the next example would obviously be
well if we have two bars and a foo
kind of sounds like a joke right
speaking of a joke two bars walks into a
foo now um
we can use in at least an moku type i'm
not expert in the immoke in mock the
mocking framework but i found something
called mock repository and that's sort
of a way for you to configure um
this sort of have the same mock
configuration for a whole bunch of mocks
you create through the repository so we
create one of those and here we instead
of passing the instance we pass in a i
guess
a component factory function uh
basically an action that when it's
called it should return and mock
instance of bar and that's what we do
here with mock repository and now in our
verification well we go and use find
components plural to find all the bars
and now we can just use the mark.get to
verify that the found instances of the
bars are actually mocked components the
mock.get method would throw an exception
if if if uh if it failed uh like if it
felt if it wasn't actually an unlocked
instance
so there's definitely some potential
here
uh these bits here the the add method
that allows you to pass in instances of
of bars of marked instances or just
instances you create yourself if you
like uh this is still sort of preview
bits for b units so if you want to play
with that that's uh
you go you have to go check the get the
previous versions in your nougat package
explore to get that
i would love if you could come and join
the discussion on the github
issues list for v-unit if you have any
feedback suggestions for how we can
prove this this is
potentially very good from creating you
know stable tests for your components
but
uh and i'm trying to sort of make it
generic so you can use your existing
blocking libraries and don't have to
basically build the marketing library
that would be a huge undertaking so if
you have any input or you may be an
experienced user of moq or insubstitute
or just block or something and you have
some tips and tricks you want to share
please come and hang out and share with
us
so
what did we see today well we started by
looking at why and what the unit is you
also saw the hello world of b units with
the counter test and
then we whoops
that was a bit too fast there and then
we looked at what we can test like
should we use markup testing or verify
markup or should we verify component
logic or and when should you switch
between the two
we also discuss techniques for creating
maintainable components and again
techniques for creating maintainable
tests
and
this is my next slide so thank you very
much for for coming and hanging out in
this you know these special
circumstances and before we get to
questions i want to give a quick shout
out sort of a pet peeve of mine but i i
have been have had uh progress trailer
against fusion sponsors sponsoring uh it
for quite a while and it's it's just
great to have companies coming into open
source and and giving back and
supporting open source
so
if you out there uh
you know have any influence on your
company
go go have a look at what open source
you're using and and maybe see if
there's any way you can support that
open source it makes a huge difference
as an open source container to get
support from from companies from from
the community i would rather have it
from companies because they
in all fairness have most likely have
more deeper pockets than
than the rest of us but it's it's a huge
help to the open source community and
helps keep motivation going so so if you
have any influence over your boss or you
are the boss consider you know figuring
to figure out another way you can
support open source and there's many
great open source libraries out there
that don't really have any support so so
please help out if you can focus or sick
but yeah thank you very much and if you
have any questions now's the time
otherwise hear my here's my contact info
and you can go and find me online if you
want to ask questions later
thank you
i can also say that i'm probably going
to hang out on the slack channel
afterwards for this room so if anybody
is watching online you can just ask your
questions in the slack channel
that's also okay
otherwise i wish you a very
great rest of the conference
you